we are six weeks away from the UK
general election which means we are in
perder unless it's absolutely critical
the folks in charge national or local
aren't allowed to announce any new
policies sign any big new contracts or
do anything official that Christina's
trying to use their power to unduly
influence the election not the most of
them will Parliament has just been
dissolved so they can all go off and
campaign on that note the rules are
complicated and depend on the size of
the area you're campaigning in but from
now until Election Day each individual
candidate can spend no more than about
15,000 pounds on all their campaigning
that's not just an advertising budget
that's all everything every penny has to
be countered tracked an invoice and if
you go over you can be disqualified even
after the election and all the scams and
tricks you can't leave thinking up to
get around that the law covers most of
them with a catch-all Clause saying you
must make an honest assessment the
political parties also have a limit on
their national campaigning budget which
is about 20 million pounds over the
whole country sounds like a lot but as a
comparison the last US election costs
six billion dollars but kicking to that
isn't as difficult as you might think
because the UK has never allowed
political adverts on television the
parties are given a small amount of free
airtime on major channels but pretty
much everyone switches off as soon as
they hear the phrase now a party
election broadcast by this year though
the parties have realised that they can
put attack ads on the internet instead
and then use their limited budget to
target those ads only at people who live
in marginal constituencies swing states
for the Americans out there if you live
in one of those you might even have seen
one of those ads before this video so
okay the parties can't advertise on TV
but surely they've got the pundits on
the news arguing for them right TV news
must be actually fair and balanced by
law generally the BBC gets an equal
amount of complaints from all sides and
then they reckon they've done their job
about right newspapers have no
restriction like that though and the
tabloids have been
happy to use that influence in the past
I swear that's what it's called here's
how the scam works go to a retirement
home and buy confidence collusion or
coercion get access to either the
residents postal votes or get nominated
as their proxy voter so you can vote on
their behalf amazingly this is only been
illegal since 2006 have you spoiled a
result well postal votes are sometimes
open for verification days before the
polls are closed there's no reason why
not it won't change the result the votes
are already cast as long as they're
still being kept secret and no one does
anything ridiculous like I don't know
tweet what they've seen well done their
actual Member of Parliament
she released it quickly admitted it and
was given an official police caution and
finally everyone who's stuck posters up
or put some temporary sign up in the
garden they have to make sure they're
taken down within two weeks if it's
anything like last time we may not even
have a government in there by then but
at least those of us who live away from
Westminster won't be constantly reminded
of it